辯方律師, 你可以開設結案層次了
法官大人, 聽過控辯雙方 這麼多證人作供之後
其實不難得到一個結論
就是對我當時人作出非禮的指控 簡直就是荒謬
大家看看我當時人
他身高六赤一全高 年輕有為, 事業有成
而且一年身一百五十萬
他為人風流蜜糖, 風趣幽默
在他身邊都不知道 多養靚身材好的異性
等著我和她去街,她怎麼會非禮人呢?
這些好條件的男人,簡直是世上罕有
連我好條件的女人也有點心動
對不起
我翻查過我當時人的戀愛紀錄
從來只有她非人,沒有女人非過她
我當時人對異性的吸引力
簡直就是爆棚了
所以她一定不會是一個鹹濕佬
因為我也是一個有專業操守的律師
我一定不會和鹹濕佬打官司
所以我肯請法官判我當時無罪釋放
冷靜點…
對不起,我發夢了,不好意思
飛機就去過龍香港了
麻煩你求安全帶先
好
不如我幫你
不好意思
什麼意思?
不要緊
那你…你握住了一隻手
對不起
如果有什麼需要,就儘管找我
這位太太
什麼太太?我還沒結婚
你什麼名字?我要求求你
看路了,沒什麼
拜託Andy,沒早?
那Paul,拜託
也沒早?
這裡是不是CK律師樓?
那你叫我秘書Apple聽電話
你幫人家回來了?
我?我昨天回來了
師兒現在很混亂
你為何不偷偷的才回來
我免得是假期給公司
你怎麼會那麼吵
是呀,現在大地震
甚麼?甚麼地震?香港有地震嗎
不是,我是說公司現在大地震
哪裡?
不好意思,你那裡很吵
我聽不到你說甚麼
有什麼回公司說, 我就來到了
就這樣吧
按了
這裡是十七, 新來的
歡迎光臨, 小姐
這裡不是十七樓嗎?
對, 沒錯
你已經完全正確地踏進
我們十七樓的健康大門, 小姐
慢著, CK律師樓呢?
CK律師樓?做不住了, 搬到下一層
現在是我們健身院的世界, 小姐
不是吧?
小姐, 我們歡迎女婚入會
行了, 不用了
小姐…我們很多明星在玩
不好意思, 我的律師在裝修
請問你有沒有辦公室
你哪位?Rebecca呢?
Rebecca?我不知道誰是Rebecca
我剛才還沒來過
行了, 我也在這裡上班
我自己照顧自己
我原來是同事, 怎麼稱呼?
Miss Mo
Miss Mo, 我叫Sandy
Sandy, 搞什麼?
看事完蛋了
這個世界怎麼走濕路?
你說什麼?
阿嬸, 是否不值得沒有人來找你
你叫我甚麼?我高你來匪訪
高我們匪訪?你自己知道自己的事
是兄弟的, 接近了他
不是, 這麼老, 你驅瘋
你幹甚麼? 幹甚麼
不行, 我知道你在這裡工作
我都知道你在哪裡工作
很可愛的弟弟, 害怕了吧
害怕他工作
打壞年輕人, 罵不行
Mismo, 回來了
還要見見吃的東西
Apple才會搞什麼?這裡
怎麼會上來你這麼長一步
你有沒有辦公室?
你的辦公室在那邊
這個吧, 這個是你的辦公室
嚴格來說, 這裡是豆腐瓶
我以前的辦公室在這裡
三倍的, 有個無敵海景
我不管, 我要在這裡開窗
這裡… 後面廁所
這裡, 這裡是電梯行動
那這裡呢?這裡
這裡當然不行
James, 為什麼?
賣辦公室
你別再用我回來, 給我一點刺激
我不是刺激你, 你過來…
你還是試試鄭鄭這個四方形
你見過三千八個辦公室嗎?
我才剛剛適應
這司機搞什麼?
弄個這樣的辦公室給我們探討
有事一件事就說出來
一筆筆那麼長
對, 怕死我了
糟糕了, 全都倒閉了
我都說女人家不要吵吵
這次你要很難洗的
快進廁所洗乾淨去
大嵐, 大嵐, 別碰
小姐, 這件事沒事了
一場誤會, 好嗎?
世奇, 哄一巴掌好小事
問題是我被人哄
現在好像不適合的是我
我這樣, 那我比較虛假
男人老舅舅是男廁, 對吧?
而且他沒有女廁
CK, 我今天第一天回到新辦公室
我怎麼知道這場樓男廁是女廁?
那倒是, 這麼久不回來
進錯了也不出奇
簡直是我錯了, 我用盡力
把臉蓋在她的手掌上
那你就創手一點
你看到有個男人
休息一下, 休息一下
褲子哭了, 你不怕嗎?
這樣也有問題
一個男人在男廁休闊
這樣也很正常
有個女人站在這裡
那你要看真實的
不用說話了, 總之說到尾
我不對, 我不穿
我這人很均衡, 行
我入錯男廁
我對不起, 好嗎?
對不起, 好嗎?
好了…大家沒事了
對了, Miss Mo 夠了大量了
你跟你們正式介紹過
娛樂天, 新來的師爺
Miss Mo, 這裡的職責
九人…
以後我會預訂娛樂天跟你們工作
大家合作愉快
她是先職的表達, 先職介紹來的
很做得來的, 你放心吧
妹子, 以前我和兩個師爺
Andy和阿波呢?
解僱了
為什麼?
人工貴, 市道不好, 什麼都說是增值
當然是請這一個頂得多
還有我的辦公室
小時候就像豆腐潤一樣
四面都是長的, 怎麼辦?
金融風暴後為正, Miss Mo
七千呎, 官落千七呎
我哪個都不想
你告了價那兩個月
不是CK實力紅口都頂不到金人
我現在在問CK, 我不是在問你
我只是幫CK回答, 人家好像…
媽媽出殯, 你又不停問
那他怎麼死的?有沒有抽筋?
有沒有死得很辛苦?有沒有噴血?
怎麼回答?
剛才那一包我寫了對不起
有沒有工作?先出去吧,好嗎?
我有事要跟司機說
先出去,阿樂,不要勞氣
我不勞氣
先喝一杯咖啡吧 我不喝咖啡
司機,你是不是弄我?
你看那傢伙的樣子,你看他的頭髮
我怕那些客人以為
古惑仔入侵我們律師樓
他做得很棒
剛才他所說的一切就解釋了
是呀, 現在槍就下了, 什麼時勢
什麼事都搞, 跟我搞完一宗案件
是樓梯
樓梯?現在才叫樓梯做
那男DJ喜歡做女人三個Ricky
現在跟那個闊太董小姐分手
找我們做代表接收私人物品
幫忙吧
那個DJ真是口臭
我們幹嘛接近濕碎案件
知道他濕碎還是口臭
有這些案件做影就好了
好, 說不定將來我們做得這些案件好
大凡明星和一副膽子, 分手了
幫忙我們
司機我們是大行, 剛才還保存了
告訴她, 現在大小通客也沒辦法
Mismol, 其實你不用道歉
是她不對
不, 我也不對
不太有問題
是, 這個是我自小的表達
她有什麼做錯的?你即本罵她
我做事公司分明你才知道
這樣就好了,是黑衣仔
從小刮到大,神神不來擔心
最重要是你多多指教她
先姐這樣說,下次我不留力了
不要帶力,剛才就行了
男人老狗,沒理由把這些放在心裡
我… 你看
打也沒反應,沒事的
以後好一點,今天不要學了,知道嗎
這些回頭你放在我的辦公室
雖然是無謂的案件
不過我們是專業的
一定要做得很好看, 明白嗎?
打打打就習慣了, 是不是?
早安…
我兩個月姐發生這麼多事
你的電腦幫你設好
好在今次阿Lok來幫我手
你知道我對電腦對媽媽的
Apple, 這些是甚麼?
甚麼?
你說那天Lok弄過我的電腦, 是嗎?
開工了, Miss Mock
怎麼樣?我驚喜了
這是什麼?
是不是劍皮開胃了?
你有沒有看我笑?
不是的
我出了這個,應該是黑人
Michael Jackson
Michael Jackson還是黑人嗎?
之前和之後吧
什麼?真的是黑了?
是不是你的線有問題?
娛樂天,待會我們的客人上來了
你坐到就行了
什麼都不要碰,不要出聲,明白嗎?
不是吧, 但要我跟開
我跟會方便一點
我不用你教嗎?
不是這個意思
但你做了一些扭氣大茶飯
總之…
一會兒你闖道, 就開口, 閉嘴
英文閉嘴不是閉嘴嗎?
你別再閉嘴了
是, 好, 知道
對方的律師現在上來了
從這一刻開始, 開口
有記者
明星分手, 聽說袁爸爸頭痛
很棒, 我的樣子不錯嗎?
完美
你先坐這邊 謝謝你
你們兩個臭小子, 過當不橫
我知道欠我的兩應不用還
天哥… 天哥叫天仔
賢樂天
我們可以開始嗎?
可以, 這邊 謝謝
在我們的當事人Ricky Fung先生
以及你的當事人董美琴小姐協議之下
就是在交還所有私人物件之後
就正式分手, 以後互不拖欠
沒錯, 但我也會代表
我當時不保留追究你
當時是Mr. Ricky Fung
誹謗董小姐法律責任的一件事
一彈還一彈
現在你們可以交還 Mr. Ricky Fung
私人物件
好, 但由於數目眾多
我想先給你清單過目 好, 清清楚楚
那怎麼辦?我… 不用了
不是, 因為我… 是, 這麼多
對了, 首先第一項
三十六條男裝內褲, 請你點手
來,吃一口
菜色很嚴重
螢光綠香
洗光了
應該是洗過了
螢光綠一條
螢光粉紅一條
黑白間條一條
深藍綠色三仔花
藍藍Q三角的泡雲一條
小鳥, 我來移個小小, 拜託
謝謝…
慢著…這條應該是泡紋
你看那種邪文化
應該是虎紋, 是不是?
請你清清楚
好, 有些問題, 先我們檢討一下
好邪有一點點出油
對, Brian, 應該是虎紋
好, 36條了, 是嗎?
是
沒事吧?
還有…還有兩隻三級ECD
三級ECD
謝謝
需要檢查一下內容嗎
當然要,我們ECD律師樓
非常專業
麻煩你,先給我們玩一次
不然真是這隻叫性愛五福臨門
而且又不自主加菜
我們不會收房,麻煩你
好
來吧…
你來得很好
這個故事給你的教訓就是
你不讓我娛樂天
即是不讓你自己
含蓄是不讓你自己走
你自處於我娛樂天
就是自處於幸福
有這個時候,各位觀眾
應該是怎樣反應
真聰明
開心發掌,歡呼發掌
讓你知道我的厲害
開心發掌
你想怎樣
不,抱不抱